I promised you a corny acronym right so
here it is four steps okay it's an
old-fashioned word but it's a good one
you want your graphs to be beautiful you
want them to be fair so what is table
the first thing you wanna do okay I've
already been giving it to you like this
just to speed things up but you have to
factorize okay if you have it already
because remember asymptotes and regions
you need it to be in a factorize form to
work out what they are right after
you've factorized a is for asymptotes
now you may want to note down okay you
have some you may have some vertical
ones in terms of horizontal or oblique
because they tell you what happens at
the ends right they compete with each
other you can't have both at the same
time so you'll have one or the other
okay bye I left this one out what do you
think is definitely intercepts okay so
even though knowing the rest of the
stuff tells us where it goes intercepts
is precision so you want to find your X
on your wise and then R is four regions
okay this will tell you where the graph
must pass through okay so this will tell
you where it's positive or negative and
if you go through that your graph still
be fair okay